(slow upbeat music)
- [Narrator] This Great Big Story
was made possible
by the Singapore Tourism Board.
(slow upbeat music)
- We try to push the
boundaries of which ingredients
can be used in a cocktail.
We've used ants to grasshoppers to kimchi,
and we've even used salmon roe
in one of our cocktails.
We are one of the only bars
in the world that focuses
on using ingredients
in the way that we do.
(slow upbeat music)
My name is Vijay Mudaliar,
and I'm the co-owner of Native.
We're a cocktail bar based in Singapore
that focuses
on working with foraging ingredients.
(slow upbeat music)
So I've been foraging for
about three years now.
As a younger bartender,
I was always interested
in like unique imported ingredients.
The environment in
Singapore is quite diverse;
sometimes we do a bit of urban foraging.
We also go out into
the forested areas and we also go down
to the coastal lines to
get things like seaweeds
and clams.
(slow upbeat music)
Using some of these unusual
ingredients we can get
certain interesting flavors.
The forage ants, for
example, contain formic acid,
so when you pop them, they taste
like little limes or lemons
because of the acidity.
For grasshoppers, what
comes out is this like miso,
vegemite, soy flavor,
which has a real savory note to it.
(slow upbeat music)
Our cocktail making process lasts four
to six months.
It usually starts from an idea
that is based on a tradition,
culture, location or the environment.
For example, our Peranakan cocktail
is based off the local Peranakan culture
and is inspired by one of the
desserts called the quay salad.
We use pandan and laksa leaf from
a local organic farmer;
a jackfruit rum,
so we're using foraged
jackfruit; also goat's milk
from a local goat's farm.
The enzymes in the jackfruits
curdles the milk, and
we get a clear cocktail.
We try to incorporate those ingredients
that have been used culturally
for over a hundred years.
(slow upbeat music)
What I like about incorporating
foraging ingredients
is that it allows us to understand
our environment a lot better
and to find forgotten
ingredients in our culture.
Hopefully in the next few years,
the idea of foraging won't feel so new.
I think people want to
experience their location,
and when people are traveling the world,
they want to have a sense of identity
at the place where they are.